Hello, everyone.
I'm very happy to
be with you today.
So I'm Caroline.
I'm one of the co
founders of DataVise.
And DataVise, we are a small
studio specialized
in human data
interactions. that means that
our job is to make visible and
usable information that is
contained in very large
volumes of data.
So, we design and we develop
tools or softwares
or application
that help people
understand data
or interact with
data or develop
new use with data.
And so we created that device
with my partners
because we were
convinced that
our brain doesn't
work like a computer.
And as humans, we need some
specific interfaces,
like visual interfaces,
for example,
to understand the complexity
inside the data.
And that's why at DataVise,
we are doing a lot of data
visualization,
like custom made,
tailor made data
visualization,
advanced data visualization,
like the one you
see, on the side,
which are projects we created
during the past years.
And so just to finish
with the presentation
, we are a team
of six people at
Dataverse with
a mix of designers
and developers,
and we are based in
Paris, in France.
So today I'm gonna
talk about a tool,
we have been working on since
the last month and
it's called Knowle.
It's a tool for mapping very
large corpus of documents,
a very large corpus
of knowledge.
And it's just
the first prototype
for the moment
you are seeing.
it's first,
the first prototype
that maps,
about fifty
thousand scientific
publication about
the coronavirus.
And with this tool,
we have a strong ambition,
really strong ambition.
We want to revolutionize
the way we,
search for
information in large
volumes of document.
And so that's the ambition,
and that's the talk
we'll be about.
And now I'm gonna
tell you a bit
more about how it goes in real
life and how we
have been working
on this. So what
was the trigger?
How did we start this
patient for such?
So when when the,
health crisis happens
in the spring,
we wondered what
we could do as
data visualization
experts because
we are not at all experts in
molecular biology
nor in virology
and we didn't know
how to produce mask.
But, we were good,
dealing with
information overload
and that emulsification,
and we discovered
that that was
a real problem
during this crisis.
for example, we
interviewed Ferdinand,
who is
a postdoctoral researcher
in a research center.
And he told us that
during this crisis,
he, he was flooded
with an avalanche
of preprints, papers,
and information,
and he feel he was stuck by
the amount of data.
It was impossible
for him to digest,
everything. and he was
not used to that,
he told us. He feels that,
it's good that there
is transparency
about all the research
works, but,
he was really afraid to waste
too much time if
he has to assess
all of all of this.
And in fact,
available information
about coronaviruses have never
been so rich or
accessible as it is now.
Because at the beginning
of the crisis,
lots of scientific
publishers,
gave free access
to their articles
about coronavirus,
to ease the research
about the disease.
But they also speed
up the review
and publication
process for new
articles, and this
led to several
thousands of new scientific
papers being published and
released each week during,
the month of April and May.
And this is
the biggest explosion
of scientific
literature ever.
So that was the trigger.
And now why do we
have a problem?
Because this practice
of open science,
it has a huge potential.
It's really fascinating,
but it also introduces
a new challenge,
which is discoverability.
So having too much content,
too much material,
we risk missing
something important,
something we will
not find because
it's drawn into the mass
of information.
That he's often
afraid of missing
an article that
already exists about,
the subject he's working on.
And for him,
checking if something
already exists or
not in the massive
amount of already published
scientific papers.
It's really complicated.
It costs too much
time, he told us.
And this discoverability
problem,
it can have very
concrete impact.
So, let's just
talk about one.
it has already claimed lives
during the Ibera
crisis in twenty
thirteen, for example.
this is a story told
by, Bernice Dan,
who is the chief
medical officer
of Liberia's
Ministry of Health.
so it's in
an article published
in the New York Times.
And she explained
that during the,
the, the eighties,
the early eighties,
there have been already one
scientific work that's pointed
out that kibaria needs to be
included in the area
where the Ebola
virus was endemic.
And this scientific work was
already warning
for the risk of
an epidemic and a risk
of a pandemic.
But this work was published in
some European
medical journals,
which are really
more confidential
than the English ones.
And so, it has
remained unknown
to local health
authority in Liberia.
And so,
that's how we had this crisis
with the Ebola
pandemic in Liberia
which costs some
lives in Africa.
And so this is
a terrible example
of what we call
dark knowledge.
And dark knowledge,
this is the part
of the scientific
knowledge that cannot be found
or cannot be reached
or cannot be used.
So back to our
coronavirus examples,
among
the scientific publication
we have been working on,
for this project,
so the publication that have
been opened and
published during
the crisis, we estimate that
fifty percent have never been
quoted and no mention by any
other scientific work.
And we've also discovered that
at least six percent of this
publication, in
not in English,
but in Chinese or
Korean or Arabic,
Russian. So those publication
who are not which
are not in English,
they will probably never be
found by any
American researcher
or any European researcher if
it's not the same language.
And that's always a problem if
a research work
cannot be found
because maybe this work was
bringing something
new and very
useful for all
the researchers.
But also if
several researchers
are working at
the same time on
the same subject
without knowing it,
but it's it's the it's
miss of time,
they they would have been able
to save some precious time if
they were aware.
And so at the end,
why do we do we have this
discoverability problem?
let's look at what
are our tools
today to deal with this
discoverability problem.
Most part of the time,
researchers are using search
engines like,
PubMed or Scopus,
but also Google,
Google Scholar,
or Microsoft
Academic when they
need to look for
scientific papers.
And according to us,
but not only us,
other other researchers have
this opinion, those
search engines
are not always the best way to
tackle with
this discoverability
problem. First,
for user experience reason,
because conventionally,
the presentation of
a search result,
it's a list paginated
like the one
you see here from
Google Scholar.
But let me ask,
how many of you are looking at
the result,
located on the third
page of results?
Only the third page.
I guess not many people,
and most part of the time,
there are hundreds
and hundreds
of pages of results.
So that's a lot
of articles that
you won't be able to find.
Second reason, it's
transparency reason.
There are arbitrariness
in the way
Google or Google
Scholar work,
but other search
engines also,
because the ranking algorithm
is not transparent.
we know, for example,
few things,
and we already know that there
are some bias.
For example, publication that
are in English language,
they are more likely to be on
the top of the list
than other language,
but also publication that have
been published in really well
known reviews or publication
that are already
cited by a lot
of articles. They
are more likely to,
have a good rank
and more likely
to be fine. So which is really
good when you are looking for
some conventional
definition of
a subject or when you
are looking for,
the common sense,
what most people are thinking
about the subject.
But maybe that's not the best
way to take a critical look at
the subject or to have a deep
understanding of a subject or
to find some raw material for
a scientific study.
So maybe we need to admit that
the most efficient
search engine
in your day to
day life when you
need to find a recipe
or the title
of a movie or
something like that,
it's not the best tool for
searching for scientific
information.
And the last reason,
I I wanted to point
out is search
engine, they are
not always good.
And in particular,
they're not good
when you don't
know to dis how when you don't
know how to describe what you
are looking for.
Because maybe you
don't know how
to name it, so maybe you don't
know what it looks like,
what you are looking for,
or maybe you don't even know
what you are looking for.
So for example,
imagine if you,
read a very
interesting article
about your research subject,
if you're a researcher,
and you would
like to find some
similar publications,
but that have been published
several years ago
in the past.
Or imagine if you
would like to
know if some other work is
refuting this article that you
find interesting.
Or imagine if you want to find
some other works
that are using
the same
experimental procedure
as this interesting
article but
for other disease,
for example.
Well, if you are in
this situation,
I wish you good luck to find
something with Google
or Google Scholar.
So in our opinion,
the user experience is key in
this solution. So, of course,
there have been
some innovation
in the field of information
research during
the last years,
like for example,
faceted filters or
similar content
recommendation, personalized
recommendation, or automatic
classification, NLP,
or entity recognition
and metadata
enrichments. But
every all this
is great and it does help,
but it's still
not enough in our
opinion because most
part of the time,
it's still designed
as black boxes,
like magic recommendations.
It's still designed
to give you
a quick answer
rather than give
giving you more
exploration capacity.
So the design choice
of search engines,
it's it's often,
to limit what you
can access easily,
And we think it's not the best
way to empower
user when they're
looking for some
scientific publication.
And according to us,
it's not
a recommendation problem
to deal with
this discoverability
crisis. It's not
about improving
how artificial intelligence
algorithm will
give you the best
three results ever.
Because we have to admit that
three result is
not enough when
you are looking
for publications
in your scientific field.
So according to us,
the solution is more about
improving
the experience to give
people access to much more
information than before and to
give people the right tools to
be able to navigate
to navigate
inside this very huge amounts
of information,
but to make them able to find
by themselves
relevant contents.
And according to us,
that's the real challenge.
And so how did we
work on this?
So let's,
share some few elements of our
methodology. So first,
we always work
with real data.
And, in this case, we,
for this prototype,
we are working with
two datasets.
the first one is LENS COVID
nineteen datasets.
LENS, it's an academic search
engine provided
by an independent
nonprofit organization.
They've selected
several thousand
of articles and patents with
that coronavirus.
The second dataset, it's,
called the nineteen,
it's the COVID-nineteen open
research datasets,
datasets which
contain more than,
two hundred thousand
scholarly articles,
and it has been
created by the Allen
Institute for Artificial
Intelligence.
So, those are the two datasets
we are working on.
We are doing a lot
of user research.
we are supporting
our experiments
with interviews
and user testing
with a small group of experts
or researchers.
We are mixing, the different
skills in our team
all the time.
For example, designers,
developers,
statisticians, we
are all working
together all
the time on the same
problems.
And also, we prototype
to solve problem.
So rather than
specifying a solution
to test, we want we prefer to
describe problem
and each member
in the team is in
charge to find
solution to try and to test.
And so in this project,
the problems we
wanted to solve,
were how to do
something that is,
that is good where
classic search
engines are not.
So for example,
how to allow users to better
understand the corpus as a as
a rule or how to help users
navigate in very large volumes
of content, or
how to help users
find something
that they cannot
describe, they don't know how
to describe, or how to reduce
the fear of missing out on
something important.
And we,
we have a strong
intuition that
mapping can be
an important part
of the solution.
In fact, it was Google
Maps rather than,
Google Search. So we were
interested in
the appearance of
Google Map,
and how this technology has
changed the use.
So we read this book,
which is really interesting,
which is called
Nebula's Again,
by Bill Kilday.
And there was this
citation that
was inspiring for us,
that that said,
no one after us,
no generation to
come will ever
be lost in the way that every
generation before was.
So our approach
was first to try
to map the application to give
another view of the corpus to
bring a physical
dimension in.
Because in data
visualization,
specialization of
the information
brings, a tangible
and physical
dimension to data.
And it plays a very positive
role in the ability of people
to appropriate
data and to play
with data. And
this is something
we have observed since a long
time in our profession.
So, it helps people,
specialization
of information,
it helps people get a mental
picture of the data.
It also helps people interact
with the data
because they feel
more able to get
their hands on
because this
physical dimension,
it breaks the black
box effect.
And also, specializations,
it also fosters
memorization and
all the theories
about the mental
palace are based on
this observation.
So, armed with this conviction
of mapping can be a solution,
we wanted to try
to what extent
this specialization,
this localization
could help to
better search in
scientific publication.
So, first we have been looking
for the best layout
to map the dataset.
So, we wanted to
find how to get
each publication
with a specific
location in the map.
So try to visualize
this corpus.
So we produce a lot
of experiments
about how to position
the publication
in the physical space.
it's a bit like if we have,
the dataset was like a ball of
clay and we try
to mold the clay
to give it a shape,
according to specific part of
the dataset.
So at the end of
all this tested,
and this is really a sample of
everything that we tested.
at the end, we kept
two approaches.
The first one was a cetacean
network graph.
So the first approach,
it's a graph of
the cetacean's link.
In, it's a network graph.
That means, it's
it's built with
a force directed, layout.
So, how does it work?
Each node here is
a publication.
And the publication,
they are linked together when
they are citing each other.
So, each time a publication is
citing another work,
we have those links.
And we use
a physical simulation
where the links act
as attractors.
It's a bit like
if we have some
balls that are linked together
by stretch, rubber bands.
And as you let go,
all the rubber bands try to
bring the balls together and
the systems stabilize in a way
that optimize
the expression of
edge length.
So it gives an idea
of the organisation,
the structure of the corpus
according to
the citation's link.
And we know that
citation's links,
they are very important in
scientific research because
science is made
by iteration and
progressive refutation.
So we were really
interested in
finding a way, to make this,
to make visible this iterative
nature of science,
to show the making
of science,
thanks to the station links.
And also, with this graph,
we were able to make visible
this dark knowledge
in the datasets.
So I don't know
if you have seen
it well,
but let me if you I don't know
if you see,
the corolla here at
the periphery of the graph.
So this corolla is made of all
the articles that
are not linked
to others. So
the fifty percent
of publication that are not
cited by anyone else.
So in this map, they
are still here.
we have this corolla,
which is the dark
knowledge that
usually you don't see and hear
it's here at the border.
It remains visible
in this map.
The second experiment,
the second way to
map this corpus,
it's a dimension
reduction map.
So here,
it's really here where we used
machine learning And here we
have another way to,
organize the datasets.
We reduce each publication to
a metadata sequence.
So it's like a unique sequence
of keywords and
information that
reflects each publication.
So we use twenty
six thousand,
different keywords to describe
the publications,
and each publication can be
summarized by
a sequence of one
and zero describing if each
keyword belongs or not
to the publication
. And after that, we have,
so this gives us vectors in
twenty six thousand
dimensions.
It's like coordinates
in a multi
dimensional space with twenty
six thousand dimension.
And then we use
a machine learning
algorithm, which
is called UMAP,
to switch position from this
multi dimensional
space into a three
d or two d space.
So we use UMAP.
It's an algorithm in the same
family as t SNE,
but it's better than
t SNE for our goal.
And this kind of algorithm
translates proximity motion in
a multidimensional
space into proximity,
into a three-dimensional
space.
in a way that
articles that are
close to each other
in the twenty
six thousand
dimension space are
still close to each other in
the two dimensional space.
And articles that
were far away
in the multi dimensional space
are still far away
in the two d space.
So it's a way to translate,
twenty six thousand dimension
into two dimension
while preserving
the topology.
And so at the end, articles,
which have
the closest sequences
of keywords are close to each
other in the map.
So here, the idea
was to replicate,
the physical
experience that you
have when you are in
the library and,
you walk around the different
shelves and you
find a book that
is interesting
for you and step
by step close to each other,
you look at, all the books,
and you will find
something that
you are not really
looking for.
So we add these
two ways to draw,
the map of the corpus.
And we they were
both interesting.
And, so we made
some user tests
to determine which
one was the most
easy to use and
to understand.
And at the end,
the dimension map
the the reduction
the the dimension
reduction map was,
really better understood,
without any doubt. So
it's really clear.
Tester felt more comfortable
with this map. They interacted
with it more
naturally than with
the citation graph.
And also, tester told us that
it was easier to understand.
It makes more sense for them.
So we,
have seen here
the potential of
machine learning for our work
at that moment,
where we achieve
a better organization,
a better localization,
thanks to machine learning.
So let's talk about
another point,
but just let me find alright.
Just one minute. I'm
short of battery.
It's Okay.
Sorry about that.
My plug was not
working anymore,
but, I'm okay now.
So, something else I wanted to
tell you about, it's
the colors because,
it's important to hear,
if you see the two, maps.
The one on the left
and the one
on the right, it's
there is a huge
difference in your ability to
save space and, to
find some location.
So we need to have some colors
that are relevant
and here colors
are reflecting clusters.
So, to get these clusters,
we also use a machine learning
algorithm. We use an algorithm
that is is called HDB scan.
it's a hierarchical clustering
algorithm algorithm.
That means that we are able to
find some parent cluster and
children cluster inside.
And it's a clustering
by density.
That means that
we can identify
some clusters even in complex
shapes in the map.
And, to, find those clusters,
we tried different different
implementation of
this algorithm.
So HDB scan,
was better than
a usual clustering
algorithm like Kamin's,
in its ability to
detect complex shapes.
But you can detect
those complex
shape in two dimension,
but also in three dimension,
four dimension,
and any of the different,
space we can
create with this,
twenty thousand twenty
six thousand as,
dimension we add on.
So we made some
different tried
different tests.
And at the end,
we found that implementing
the clustering
algorithm in a ten dimensional
space was, give us
the best result.
Just a a small,
point again about,
the caller. First,
it's it shows you
the different
clusters, but also we can show
you some other dimension.
For example, I'm sorry.
Just for example,
here, we can,
use the color to
display to show
the number of citation.
So we can change dynamically
the color of the of
the publication.
And here you have some other
patterns that appears.
And for example,
we are able to see
that the cluster
talking about coronavirus in
biology and virology
is the most
cited in in this corpus.
And just let me give you few,
explanation about,
the class the labels.
So the labels, we
also find them,
using some data treatments.
And here we try
to find the most
used keywords to
describe the cluster.
So for example,
we found the keywords that are
most frequent in
the cluster and
not in the rest
of the corpus,
in comparison with the rest of
the corpus.
So let's,
finish with the rest
of the interface
because this map is
not working alone.
there are some user interface
element to form
a tool and give
users some features
to explore further.
So we have, like
in Google, like,
the ability to zoom,
zoom in, zoom out,
or to pan,
or to hover any
article and see
its link.
But we have also,
the ability to use
some filters.
So for example,
it's really basic because it's
just a prototype,
and we have been focusing more
on the map. But so you can add
some filters for
the year or for
the field of study
or the keywords.
And when hovering, a filter,
you see directly which part of
the map is concerned.
And so, you can create this
filtered version of the map
according to what's
important for you.
And you can also
display the list
of all the publication.
and you have
this correspondence
between the map and the list.
You can investigate further on
one article. So,
you can select an article and
you can see it's metadata and
the abstract and everything we
get we we have for
this article.
But also you can
explore the citation
the citations.
So papers which
are citing this
paper or references
the bibliography.
And we can, for example,
display the list
of all the citing
papers and see where they are
on the map, if they are from
different fields
of study or if
they are from the same
fields of study.
So this is really, useful.
And also we can display a list
of similar publications.
So if you find something that
looks good for you,
we can automatically,
find the closest
one and display
the closest one.
So this,
is the first prototype we have
been working on,
and, voluntarily,
we have not put any
search box yet.
So this is really,
because we wanted to keep this
for later. We wanted first to
explore the potential
of the map
and the complementarity
between,
the search, options
like filters
and things like
that on the map.
And so the questions we ask
ourselves is how does
it fit together,
this map,
with the user
experience of a classic
map like Google
Map and the more
classic user
experience element
like the filters on the list?
And we have done user
testing on that,
and the user test
show that users,
still use the map relatively
little as
an exploration medium,
but more as a feedback,
as a way to evaluate
the results
of their search,
as a way to see,
if the filters they're using,
is it relevant
for them or not,
or how many, result they will
get or not. But
for the moment,
the map is not
really the first
way to interact
and to look for
something. So this
is interesting,
but we would like to see to
investigate how we can,
make the most out of this map
for the searching capacity.
And so, we have still
a long way to go,
still progress to
make to succeed
in this challenge of improving
the research experience in
scientific publication.
But this is just
a first step.
The next step,
we would like to
try to visualize
relations between entities
extracted from
the publication.
So, not anymore mapping
the publication
and the relation
between articles,
but mapping
the relation between
entities relation between what
articles are talking about.
For example, we can extract
disease or molecules
or viruses,
part of the body,
gene, and so on.
And all these entities are
discussed inside publication.
So if you read one, two,
or three publication,
you will see
the relation between
those entities.
for example, you will see that
an article is
making a relation
between a virus and a part of
the body on a virus
and a gene.
But you cannot do this for
thousand and thousand
of publication.
But by automatic
extraction and
by visualization,
specialization,
we can make appears
the relations
between entities for
the whole corpus.
And maybe we will make some
correlation appear
that you will
not have seen
other way because
this is what you
can do when you
can visualize such
massive amount
of relations.
So I'm hope,
so this will be
an expert type.
We are working on
it at the moment,
and I really hope
I will be able
to share it with you soon and
to give you some more feedback
so that this mapping,
the capacity to
improve the way
we search.
So this, right, this
is the the end.
This is the story of what we
have been working on
since the beginning
of this crisis.
and I'm I'm really curious of
your question now.
So I'm gonna have a look at
the at the chat.
Hi, Caroline.
It's James here. Can
you hear me okay?
Yes. I can hear you. Cool.
Sorry I was late
at the start.
There was a previous session
that I overran.
So, yeah, if
people can send in
questions. I don't
know whether
you can see there are some
questions already
in the chat box,
that have been
coming through.
I can see some
people are typing
as well.
Yeah. Alright.
I don't know if I go
over the question
by order of if, I can,
I can work backwards if that's
helpful and read
out the questions.
Alright. so question,
did you experiment
with modularity
based clustering methods?
How did you validate,
or test the clusters
with users?
Alright. We tried mostly,
we tried different algorithm,
but we were,
we really wanted to
have a hierarchical
clustering algorithm.
And so we tried several,
and we tested
them with users.
And
the the the the most important
thing was how people feel they
can find something
in the map.
So we were showing them up to
new testers. And if they feel
they were lost
and if they feel
it was like a mess, we, yeah,
we were not keeping
the algorithm.
Great. Thanks.
another question.
How did you test the layout
algorithm to arrive
at the dimensionality
reduction method,
was better? Yeah.
It's it's the same thing.
we first,
we we see what's
the result when
we map the,
the the publication.
So what's the result
of the algorithm?
Does does it bring something
better in terms of
specialization,
in terms of capacity to,
to have your publication that
are not all at the same,
in the same ball
at the center,
but that are
positioned differently
in the space.
So most mostly,
the idea was to find the best
algorithm to create some space
with more,
publication and
some space with
the lesson to see
those clusters
appears. So the capacity of
making clusters
appear was a very
important point in evaluation
of the different
algorithm we tried.
And after that,
once when we feel
it was good,
we show it to our testers and
we ask some feedbacks and we
give testers some basic
task of finding,
publication inside the map or
describing the map and we see
which one was more
efficient. Great.
Thanks. another question.
You mentioned that users are
less likely to explore
using this map.
How have you
attempted to enable
this exploration?
Sorry.
I missed the users
are more likely to.
So you mentioned
that users are
less likely to explore
using this map.
So I think
the question is around
what plans do you have for
developing exploration,
functionality,
tools, capabilities? Yeah.
RID is really to
have an interface
that makes some
rebounds between
classic, filtering
and searching
options and the map.
Like, if all the interface was
reacting at the same
time when you,
perform some action.
So, for example,
if you zoom somewhere
in the map,
it should,
update at the same
time the filters
on the list.
And if you feel one filter is
interesting for you,
it's which it should
show directly
how part of the map,
you will lost.
Or if you, get interested by,
for example, one article,
you should be able to see at
the same time,
you can you you you should be
able to read at the same time
the abstract and see what's
the impact of this article,
on the rest of
the scientific field,
for example. So,
the idea is giving you more
options to go from one article
to another, to go from one ID
to another, to go
from one keyword
to another because it's really
complicated to know which one
is the good keyword for you.
And this is something that is
really common in
the interviews,
we made is that,
at the beginning,
people are are naming things
differently. and according to
the location,
people are describing things
differently in
the publication.
So if you have to
rely only on one,
two, three keywords,
you're really,
there is really
a risk that you
miss something.
And that's exactly the fear of
researchers, who
are working on
a specific subject.
it's the fear of missing out
some work that
have been already
published and that they don't
find because they don't know
what is the correct keyword to
find that.
and this is why,
any option to
interact with this,
corpus of document
that doesn't,
ask you to describe
something with Word,
but by proximity,
by going from one to another,
clicking here,
clicking here to
see what's the result.
It's it's good.
Perfect. Thanks.
Thanks, Caroline.
that was a really fantastic,
really interesting talk.
hopefully, you've
had a look at
some of the, compliments in
the chat channel.
I think a lot of
people enjoyed
that and found it
really interesting.
I'd ask if, anyone
has any questions,
further questions
for Caroline,
just post in
the the leaders, Slack,
chat, and, hopefully,
she'll be around
to pick that up.
So now we're moving on to,
the US time zone, coverage.
So we have the welcome address
for the for the US,
part of the conference.
So, I would direct
people over to there,
and we'll we'll
get started with
handing over
the virtual baton.
Thanks. Thanks very much all.
Thanks, Caroline.
Thank you, everyone.
I remain available in
the Slack channel,
so don't don't hesitate to ask
your question. Yeah. Great.
Thank you very much.